hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday
September 19 2022.
what's going on how are ya
how's it going
how'd you do yesterday you gambling
lunatics
as of right now I picked four games
against the spread no freckles is 0-3
I got the Bears laying tent no given ten
no get in 10.
land given getting they're getting 10.
all they gotta do is not lose more than
10 or I'm gonna do the disgraceful I'm
gonna go oh and four nice defense nice
[__] defense
there we go third down 10 46 to go in
the first quarter
if you're re-watching the game with me
um
who'd you take Bill who'd you take
yesterday I first of all I bet against
my own team because I just [__] I
don't know
I just got a bad feeling this year right
and I should have known Bill Belichick
coming off a loss playing the Steelers
we always beat the Steelers how many
[__] times can we beat the [__]
Steelers
oh didn't mean to knock that over the
[__] uh you know Mitch trubitsky
I like that guy his big [__] thing is
he'll take a sack other than that I
think he's a solid quarterback
and um
I don't know I took the Pats I mean
that guy should at least knock that ball
down that [__] [__] touchdown you
gave up
Pittsburgh before the [__] half that
ended up being the difference we ended
up winning the goddamn game although I
didn't see the second half because I
took my daughter to go see one of these
these freaking movies and I'm I'm
[__] done with these [__] kid
movies
the two things they want to do give them
nightmares and make them cry every
[__] one of them every [__] one of
them
you know it starts off your kid's happy
halfway through they introduce the
[__] creep you know these are kids
they haven't met [__] yet unless
you're a
bad parent you know can they [__] can
you keep them in the Santa Claus world
even those old Santa Claus want
you know in that [__] abominable
snowman comes out starts [__]
screaming and [__] you you sit down you
forget you're like oh I'm gonna this is
gonna be it gives me a great little
bonding experience and you start off
you're having a great time and about
[__] 40 minutes into the movie your
kid's sitting in your lap going Dad I'm
scared I don't I don't want to do this
you know
I don't know
there's always like some some sort of
[__] painful backstory
you know and uh you know and then the
other thing too is then when they
finally [__] win the good guy comes
back and wins can they just end the
[__] movie
oh good we did it they just keep more
obstacles more obstacles more obstacles
drag it out there's no suspense
it's a kids movie we know the [__]
good guys are gonna win just end it the
parents want to go home they just keep
going and going I mean I lost [__]
track with this [__] movie how many
times it just kept going and going and
going and going
Jesus Christ and then I have to do this
[__] move and if I do this move I'm
gonna [__] die and then of course he
does it then I go well how like I'm not
gonna make him [__] die if he does it
huh
Jesus Christ
my kid sit in my lap the whole [__]
time
um anyway so I missed the second half is
what I was trying to say there
um I had such [__] high hopes for
that I was like you know what being a
[__] great dad here you know I was
gonna hang an extra day in Philly and go
see Porcupine Tree and I said no I'm not
doing that I'm doing the exact opposite
as much as I love that band I'm going to
take a 6 30 a.m flight I'm gonna land at
[__] nine something out in L.A I'm
gonna hang with my kid all day you know
the kiddos and then on the next day I'm
gonna watch a little bit of football but
I'm going to the movies all right we're
having a dad weekend
all right
then I lost all my bets and and my kid
got scared at the movie and then the
whole [__] thing went to [__]
[Music]
it all went to [__] it was actually a
good movie I just I guess my kid isn't
old and they're really realities I don't
think my kid's old enough to see those
kinds of movies it has to be a straight
rated G movie
um
because it was a really good movie like
I was enjoying I couldn't enjoy the
movie because my kid was getting scared
but
um I actually like the movie there there
we go see that see this is the new me I
flip out I scream and yell and then I go
you know what you're right it was
actually it's actually me maybe I could
have looked at the rating
I mean I don't know I I figure it's if
it's a [__] cartoon
you know
I don't know
um anyway Pat's won [__] psyched
about that I didn't feel bad betting
against him because I figured no matter
what you know I'd be happy
either I win my Beta they win the game
it's kind of a good thing
you know there's not not a lot of
Happiness as you're going [__] on
your way to going Owen four did he get
another first down [__] Aaron Rodgers
how the [__] did he end up down there
third and 15.
come on come on come on get him get him
get him get all [__] yes there you go
down on the ground yeah now celebrate
like you just won the game yeah they're
still going to get what that was not a
home run it was not a home run
I was a sacrifice fly
sacrifice fly they're going to kick a
[__] field goal here
doesn't that defensive end realize I
have money on him
um
that guy down the middle [__] fell
down that's what happened that's my
that's my stand-up comedian analysis
Mason Freemason Crosby
he's got this one all day this is going
to be right down the [__] middle I'm
not trying to jinx you at all
I was off to the left but it's still
good
um all right still up by seven
I'm sure the Bears have a good
quarterback
[Music]
um anyway the Jets
Jets
Joe Flacco
coming from behind who the [__] they
beat the [__] Ravens
is that who they beat there's no [__]
way they beat the Ravens then I bet that
I didn't bet that game I might have bet
that game
I'm so [__] busy I don't remember
what I bet I just know I was watching
all day looking at ticker going I didn't
think that was going to happen
I didn't think that oh I definitely
didn't think that was going to happen
all right NFL scores here NFL NFL here
we go
NFL scores
Rams held on I don't know if they
covered
a crazy block punt for [__] touchdown
that's the [__] as a gambler you're like
what the [__] and then the other person
gets to brag that they pick the other
team it's just like your team didn't
cover my team [__] up that's like the
Chiefs
the chief's covered they [__] covered
man foreign
and then they just think they're [__]
up by 10 points I got them laying four
and a half and then they go into a
[__] prevent defense just give the
[__] Chargers a touchdown
just give it to them
and then they get one first down they
take a [__] knee do they call me do
they ask me what I have on the game [__]
no
Paul versus Giants win again
Paul versus Giants are 2-0 but I gotta
tell you
I have to tell you the shocker
the Shocker has got to be the 2-0 Miami
Dolphins
what the [__] is that score
where is that score where is that score
well that's last week
you know you think if you just put it up
this is week three all right Bill's
Titans Vikings Eagles tomorrow Bears
Packers Bengals Bengals Jesus Christ the
[__] snake bitten
how about the Cardinals coming back I
saw that one
Broncos win didn't cover
uh Rams win did not cover 49ers beat the
[__] out of the [__] Seahawks
Saints started off all right Tom Brady
comes back you know what's scary Tom
Brady won by 10 points and only threw
for 190 something yards Tom Brady has a
running game ladies and gentlemen oh the
Dolphins beat the Ravens I'm sorry in an
old school [__] shootout
42-38 the [__] Colts
heads are spit in the Jaguars 24-0 Bill
we know the scores let's hear an opinion
or shut up oh the Jets beat the Browns
came back and beat the Browns
um
so so far everyone in the AFC East has
won
now here's my thing
here's what I'm wondering right next
week the [__] bills play the Dolphins
can you imagine after all the hype the
[__] Buffalo Bills have gotten
okay if they lose next week down in
Miami
Viola however the [__] you say no
there's like 1500 different
pronunciations in every analyst on St on
TV calls them Tua
[Applause]
um
that's like ante tacompo they just call
him The Greek Freak
Giannis then you got to deal with
Giannis out there and then I could go
ante tacompo
um
all right come on Bears drive down the
field can you save me the embarrassment
of going oh and four
oh and four come on establish the
running game
what are we doing is this another
unimaginative [__] Chicago Bears
offense didn't they win last week
did they win I don't [__] know
um anyway
so is that my breakdown of the week
breakdown of the week because I I
[__]
you know I believe week one
stupid
I believed week one and I [__] paid
for it and I went against everything
that I like I should have taken the
charges because I always say division
rivalry games are close
you know if you get more than like three
points and they're both good teams you
know I usually go with the [__]
Underdog but I believe what the Chiefs
did during week one beating the [__] out
of the Arizona Cardinals I believed in
that
[__] prevent defense [__] suckers um
anyway
um before I keep whining about movies
and football games
uh
uh big thank you
to everyone that came out in Washington
DC
and everybody who came out in
Philadelphia
might have been my two favorite shows of
the year
and I don't even know why because I've
had so many fun shows
um
am I talking about Fenway was amazing
Jesus Christ what am I talking about but
I mean just as far as the inside gigs
how about that one
um
right before I went up in DC I fell
asleep for like eight minutes took like
a power nap and it just cleared my head
and I went up there and I was and DC is
always fun because it's such an
interesting like
it's like La where it's just a like you
you just don't meet anybody who's from
there
and then it's the same kind of thing
where people are nervous to talk [__]
because you never know who's sitting at
the table next to you so like even the
Democrats right the [__] the Larry
liberals even they have this
conservative vibe uh it's very Hollywood
very Hollywood
um they've always said that right
Washington DC's Hollywood for ugly
people which I don't think so
you know
I think Joe Biden and Donald Trump back
in the day but good looking guys
weren't they
Obama Obama had a jump shot too had a
little athletic little [__] Wrinkle
in there to [__] uh bring on the
ladies
you know George Bush was a you know best
looking guy we were talking about me and
verse the best looking guy ever to be
president had to have been John F
Kennedy
you know granted he was young as [__]
you know what I mean
maybe that's why they took him out they
were just [__] jealous you know same
way they were jealous of Tom Brady
um
yes I did just connect those two things
I did
I did and I stand by it because that's
what you do nowadays you say something
ignorant and then you stand by it and
then then you say it louder
and uh you act like you're you're
Fearless
that's what I do
um
anyway
uh so
there was so much [__] I said there was
something I said when I was on stage in
Philly oh that's going in the act now I
can't remember what the [__] it was
but uh
I forgot my [__] sneakers man I was
gonna wear those those Dr J Converse
is a little subtle nod
to one of the greatest teams I ever saw
the 1983 Philadelphia 76ers and I forgot
to wear them and on top of all of that I
wore Jordan once
and if you ask any mouth breathing
NBA fan who's the greatest team of all
time they'll say oh 96 Bulls I know that
because I watched enough Talking Heads
tell me that they that they're just a
foregone conclusion
I mean think about the showtime Lakers
think of the [__] people that were on
that team
Magic Johnson Kareem Abdul-Jabbar
[__] what's his face coming down the
lane with his Kareem glasses for some
reason
I keep thinking Jamal Wilkes this wasn't
him James Worthy
Jamal Wilkes
Michael Cooper
Norm Nixon
I think Jamal left and Norm came in
if I remember correctly
Orlando Woolrich
Linda Woolrich I believe he was on
no that wasn't him that was Kermit's I
thought Orlando Woolwich was the guy who
punched Rudy uh John tomovich it was
Kermit something or other
just [__]
there's a fight he just reacted punched
Rudy in the face and Rudy had to go to
the hospital and he had this weird taste
in his mouth and he was tasting spinal
fluid
and that's what happens when a guy six
foot ten or seven feet tall throws a
[__] punch like a like a boxer
I mean he [__]
uh yeah you read up on that one oh you
youngsters
what was that Kermit Washington was it
Kermit Washington and then like it
became of course some racial thing
because the guy who got punched was
white the guy through the punch was
black and then all these people out
there I don't know what their deal is
the 1800s
version of my people that still exists
for whatever [__] reason
because of uh propaganda and [__] like
that I have no idea dude when are they
going to change CNN to the Donald Trump
Channel what are they just going to call
to I've never seen a channel that
pretends they don't want something they
want so bad do you know how bad they
want that [__] guy back
so they can have a nice easy day at work
for four years I can't believe what he's
doing you don't care
buy another Firehouse
um anyway
I am uh what am I doing here
I'm losing my ass is what I'm losing
here but the Bears are driving
this is what I need
score a [__] touchdown
score a [__] touchdown here and then
I'll be up by 14 [__] points and
that's the kind of [__] I need to oh man
did they miss that call or they call
that
sort of tackle the guy here what do we
got here what are we looking at old man
eyes
Oh Billy Amber vision
that looks like a busted plate running
it baby
[Music]
this is how you gamble
it's not how you gamble look at me
getting all excited in the first I'm
acting like that guy that just sacked
[__] Aaron Rodgers like the game's
over
this was huge for me you gotta love a
running back number 32.
if you were number 32 and you were
running back when I was a kid and your
name was OJ you were the [__] and I'm
not just talking about Simpson I'm also
talking about Anderson O.J Simpson O.J
Anderson and O.J Rabinowitz
um no there was no OJ ribbonowitz uh who
else was 32. Tony Dorsett was 33.
Wilbert Montgomery was 31. why do I
remember this [__] mostly tatupu was 30.
Mark Van Egen was 30.
like I can't remember [__] anything
from yesterday or earlier today and I
can remember all of this [__]
Russ Francis was 81 he was a tight end
who actually stopped playing football I
read up because he wanted to concentrate
on Aviation
and then actually came back with the
49ers because he wanted to make some
more money so the guy could buy himself
a plane I mean that that's that is a man
with the plan by the way did I mention
that he looked like Burt Reynolds
like a giant Burt Reynolds and he lived
in [__] Hawaii I mean this guy had
life figured out then he goes with the
49ers and plays with arguably the
greatest quarterback of all time Joe
Montana
he's still in the argument and he goes
and he wins a Super Bowl
wins the Super Bowl
you know and then gets to go fly his
Planes I mean that that right there
is amazing
um I had a little dad moment as a father
don't you always go online and you look
at [__] that you'd buy
if like you didn't have responsibility
um I was looking I went on the Porsche
website
and when I was a kid like the Porsche
Target I just loved that car I love the
rims I love that little silver roll bar
type of looking thing that it had
um and the [__] tea top the glass
t-tops and [__] it was just I loved it
right so they brought the target back
I'm not a big Porsche guy but they
brought it back when they did they
brought it back in this ridiculous
orange that was like
the color of my refrigerator here in my
little room here by the garage
um the same [__] deal
like orange and Browns
and like [__] potted plant green
whatever the Ford truck was called like
Earth Tones were in and for some reason
orange was in
and
I remember uh when that car came out
and I showed it to Rogan
and he goes that's a cool car he goes
you're not gonna get that color are you
I was like yeah I love that card because
why the [__] would you get that girl
[Music]
like you know you come on man you're my
age you don't remember the 70s I had a
10-speed bike the same color so anyway
um
but that definitely made me think
because Joe has amazing taste in cars
like the the ones that he's
gotten and redone and [__] uh
it definitely made me think but I was
still like but then I ran it by Dean Del
Rey and I think he's part of the same
70s that I'm from he's like oh dude
that's [__] rad right so
it was just something in the back of my
head then I knew I was never gonna do
and I went to the website and I was so
heartbroken they don't offer it in that
color anymore not like I was gonna buy
it I got two kids I'm gonna buy a
[__] two-seater
you know sports car come home
hi honey like that guy in the rose petal
movie
beautiful [__] world America America
the beauty whatever the [__] it was
called I actually like that movie it
just came out 20 something years ago I
know I can remember Mark Van Eagen was
number 30. and Robert Newhouse was
number 44 and blocked for number 33 Tony
Dorsett and John Fitzgerald was the
center I can remember that but I
American Beauty
right there you go
remember when the wife comes home that
was like every guy's fantasy
you know
they always thinks it's it's you know
some [__] supermodel in a bikini
like in [__] Chevy Chase Christie
Brinkley eating like a Ferrari looking
at you wanted to swim naked with you the
reality
is for most married guys I'd say most
I'm gonna try to speak for most of them
what it is is you go out and buy
something that you want and you don't
even ask your wife you just buy it and
when she asks you what it is you tell
her exactly what it is with go [__]
yourself tone
I can't remember the curry button like
what is that he's like that is a 1969
whatever [__] Pontiac Firebird
whatever the hell he had
um I mean well I think that's [__]
because my wife doesn't give a [__] if I
go out and go buy something she's the
reason why I have my old truck
I had the Catholic guilt I couldn't buy
it she goes why don't you just [__]
buy one of these cars
I go yeah yeah you're always looking at
him
just [__] buy it
I was like all right
and then I bought it and I was like holy
[__] I didn't know you could do that
foreign
problems people I had a lot of [__]
like there was a lot of [__] that I
could have just done and I didn't
realize I had it I didn't know you could
just do that
I didn't know that seven to three baby
it's really 17 to three come on
what do we got here what town is it
ah [__]
nice in come pleat
I don't like rooting against Aaron
Rodgers this is my money talking I love
Aaron Rodgers
you know
him at this point he's like that one
decent family member and a [__] up
family
and like when everyone around town talks
about the family but they always go but
but Aaron's nice he is isn't he God how
did he end up in that family
um
[Laughter]
uh and also
as far as bucket list places to go see a
game man that [__] place just lives
up to the hype and the fans are
incredible
that was one thing I'll tell you
like as far as classy fans
uh Green Bay Packer fans
because there was Seattle fans the
anti-class
fans
um there's some about living near an
ocean you just become a [__] [__]
I don't know what it is but like people
in the middle of the country at least
pretend that they're nicer you know like
St Louis Cardinals fans
they seem to be nice you know
I don't know and then you know what it
is then you actually [__] sit down
you talk to somebody and you listen to
how they see the world
you never know how it's going to go you
can meet like some complete [__]
[__] and then they'll just say
something really like [__] profound
or empathetic or you could just be with
somebody who's just like wow man
what a decent oh my God I remember that
that had me early on in my career
oh [__] wow I haven't thought about this
in years I would tell you guys the story
of [__] I was doing some gig
one of my first road gigs and I was
opening for this guy
and he wanted to go water skiing
are you [__] kidding me
did he just did you just [__] reach
out and get a first step nice nice like
that spot there you go 37 good call
um
it was one of the most amazing things I
saw as far as like this dude wanted to
go water skiing it was right after Labor
Day he knew everybody had put their
boats away
so he just went up there and started
riffing about how much he loved to go
water skiing knowing
he told me he goes there's going to be
some woman in the crowd that's going to
say to her husband or boyfriend
come on he's in town you should take him
out
I go there's no [__] way nobody's
gonna oh God damn it first down I'm like
there's no [__] way that that's gonna
eat
I didn't say that's what I was thinking
I was so new and uh and he did he went
up there and he did it and then this
[__] guy took us out on the lake and
you could see it in his face he was he
was not happy as he was uncovering his
boat and doing all of this [__]
maybe he hadn't put it away because it
was still in the water it was a lake I
don't know do you guys take you take the
boats out I don't know how it [__]
works you take it out right so maybe he
just had it covered and didn't want to
do it but he was not into it and
um it's a one and only time I went water
skiing he brought the headliner up and
he got up and he was [__] buzzing all
around the lake having a good time so
the guy was still kind of grumpy because
it's like you know he's [__] burning
up gas and [__] [__]
[__] Heckle him
come on Bears you're supposed to be
known Brett by having a defense
um sorry for screaming like that
I'm gonna try to be more mature here
so then he goes to bring me up
you know to go water skiing I never been
water skiing in my life and he like
dragged me across the lake for like I
swallowed half the lake I was I
eventually I was getting up but he was
laughing his ass off and it then became
it became worth it for him that he was
dragging this comedian across the
[__] lake so then we go back to the
house and they're just the nicest people
ever and they bring out finger
sandwiches and all of this [__]
and everything's going great and then
all of a sudden the guy driving the boat
wants to start telling us jokes and like
right out he just just racist n-word
jokes
and we're sitting there like hey yeah I
don't know about that and then the
wife's going like oh come on just you
know saying the husband and settle down
so
who knows right just because somebody
acts DC you have no [__] idea
kind of like I have no idea what I'm
talking about because I got half my
[__] brain on this goddamn game here
uh
um
come on
man in motion Man in Motion so CFL the
guy everybody would be running around
all right second and eleven here you go
just [__] it up and get a field goal for
the love of God all right let me read
some advertising here for the week oh by
the way I forgot to mention Josh Adam
Maya's opened up for me this week
as far as I know he's never done an
arena dude this guy went out there like
he was [__] headlining the show
Charisma for days
being silly goofy [__] around just
having a great time
uh um I was blown away I said at the end
of the week I was like dude I mean I
wouldn't have hired you if I didn't
think you're going to get the job done
but Jesus Christ
you [__] killing up there
and he said oh yeah no thanks a lot I
appreciate it
um all right let's see here let's uh
let's where's the advertising
where is the advertising true classics
I thought this was an email that doesn't
sound like advertising that's all right
true classic everybody today's episode
is brought to you it's brought to you by
true classic guys let's talk about
t-shirts man
finding that perfect fitting shirt can
be terrible terrible
um I swear to God man the thing you know
[__] t-shirts either too tight it's
too itchy there's there's the tag on the
back it doesn't fit right it's just boxy
you know you can never get the uh you
know whoever folds them just creases
them with a [__] nuclear ion or
something anyway luckily there's true
classic true classic wants to make every
man look good and feel good tighter fit
in the chest and sleeves to make your
arms pop and room in the Torso to keep
things cozy oh so this is it's not going
to be unflattering
uh we have an exclusive deal for our
listeners we want to hook you up with
some true classic for a limited time
only get 25 off with the code Burr
b-u-r-r at trueclassic.com almost all
men's t-shirts are designed to look good
on a certain body type think skinny
models with six packs but most of us
aren't packing anything but a few beers
and there's nothing wrong with that
um my dudes it's simple oh that they
gave me the hip copy my dudes it's
simple man check it
you're you are wearing the wrong clothes
dig uh true classic tees taper off
towards the bottom but they fit tighter
around the chest and shoulders well it's
about [__] time
it's about time they made men's clothing
that tricked the ladies out there and
then they could be disappointed when we
disrobe uh you can throw on that truth
this is our push-up bruh
you can throw on that true classic with
confidence knowing we've got your bases
covered true classic will make you feel
your best by accentuating the places the
eyes goes to first wink wink uh whether
you have abs or flabs their clothes look
great on all body types skinny dudes big
dudes buff dudes and my dudes dude uh
true classic has you covered get
comfortable get going and upgrade your
wardrobe with true classic get 25 off at
trueclassic.com with codeburr free
shipping including included on purchases
over 100 100 risk-free guaranteed with
the 30-day return policy true classic
when you look good God damn it you feel
good
[__] me touchdown God damn it
all right
all right I'm still off I'm still up I
don't like this at all I don't like this
at all where are we we're in the second
quarter all right
we got to go down and get some points oh
you think so Bill all right solo stove
you know life's best moments happen
around a roaring fire
uh
yeah tell it to people at the Honda
Hindenburg uh in a smokeless fire pit
with from solo stove makes your outdoor
moments even more memorable memorable
because instead of having to constantly
Dodge campfire fumes you can sit back
relax and actually enjoy the fire yeah
they take the smoke out of it upgrade
with your backyard upgrade your backyard
with the solo Stove fire pit and create
uh story worthy moments without the
Fireside fumes stainless steel
construction designed to regulate
airflow and burn more efficiently solo
Stow fire pits are brilliantly
engineered to be easy to use and they're
built to last easy to light with a few
bits of stata your fire is blazing in
minutes they're so confident you'll love
it they'll offer a lifetime warranty and
a 30-day free return policy right now
you can get big discounts on all fire
pits during solo stoves Labor Day sale
and use promo code Burr at solostove.com
for an extra ten dollars off that's
solostove.com promo code bird for ten
dollars off on top of their incredible
Labor Day discounts but hurry the Labor
Day sale ends September 11th
all right what do we got here oh and
lastly but not leastly people it's
simply safe
here's a question is there anything more
precious than the safety of you and your
loved ones of course not so isn't it
strange that not all home security
companies truly put you first old school
home security companies set you up with
outdated technology they over Chad you
um Jesus Christ what kind of [__]
return was that
guys slowing down
you believe he was playing [__] one
two three red light
um now spin around I didn't say Simon
Says overcharge you for service and lock
you into binding multi-year contracts
that's why I use and Trust Simply Safe
home security SimpliSafe protects you
with Cutting Edge security technology
powered by 24 7 Professional monitoring
agents who always have your back with 24
7 Professional monitoring Simply Safe
agents call you the moment a threat is
detected into Spanish police or First
Responders in an emergency if you are
not home or can't be reached Simply Safe
blanket your home in protection
um
we're out I'll [__] act like there's
a fumble uh our uh sorry
simply say blanks to your home and
protection uh with Advanced sensors for
every room window and door HD security
cameras for inside and outside your home
smarter ways to detect motion that only
alert you when the threat is real and
even and even Hazard sensors that
instantly detect fires floods and other
threats to your home our monitoring
experts use proprietary Advanced
response technology to visually confirm
when a break-in is real so you can get
the highest priority police dispatch
customize the perfect system for your
home in just a few minutes
did he just get sacked on third down at
simplysafe.com go today and claim a free
indoor security camera plus 20 off with
interactive monitoring go to Simply Safe
s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e.com slash bird
there's no safe like simply safe
you know what I just realized isn't the
bar isn't this the team that that
[__] Aaron Rodgers always beats
and he talks [__] about it
third and 19.
you got to call the old Razzle Dazzle
play the Flea Flicker Statue of Liberty
or dump it off behind a couple of
linemen
slip and fall yeah not run like you just
run what are you doing
yeah yeah my job's to tackle him and I
did
is that guy running down the field when
they let up that [__] touchdown on
the last Drive I don't think he was
okay skinny Magoo here
this guy's whole [__] body is the
same size as the same circumference as
his leg
it's gonna be a good punt good punt come
on all the way down the field all the
way down the field all the way all the
way not even nearly far enough fair
catch all right I'll take that
ah [__] me
all right okay let's let's let's let's
turn away from the TV for a moment
people let's turn away from the [__]
the the solo stove that is my [__]
Australia
uh when are you coming to Australia you
bald red [__]
um I don't know man I haven't been there
in like seven years I can't believe it
I've been there in for [__] ever
uh I miss it I love it
I'd love to come back but I have I have
two kids so I don't know what to tell
you I did do during covid
I did do one of those things where you
know I was online
and um I [__] uh
it was broadcast over there
you could watch me in your apartment
that's the only thing I did but I will
tell you this
um
I miss going over there most beautiful
beaches I've ever seen
and uh Little Creatures beer was one of
my favorite beers I ever had
plus I was drinking it right after I
went to bond Scott's grave paid my
respect
to the man and uh I went there it was
Australia day I was in Perth
you know I walked into the ocean a
little bit just to say I I've been in
the Indian Ocean how many oceans have
you been in
how many oceans are there
Jesus Christ is the Atlantic the Pacific
the Indian
the uh Arctic
wait I can name the continents well what
am I a [__] sailor I don't know what
this [__] is all right
how many
how many oceans this is one of these
things I had to memorize and I've
how many oceans are there I'm gonna say
five
four
wait did I name them all Atlantic
Pacific Indian and art I [__] did it
that's my two
not like everybody says look at Fredo
[__] nailing it for some reason I
thought that was gonna be so I'm
thinking C's
which is what I get in school if I did
well
the Baltic Sea
c c remember that
summer school that great [__] movie
um
underrated comedy from back in the day
Stoner [__] comedy
um all right now I lost where the hell I
was
where was I
where was you guys I was looking for you
um I would love to come back there's a
whole bunch of places I want to go back
there I want to do that run again all
through Australia New Zealand Singapore
Hong Kong and Mumbai India I I that was
one of the most incredible experiences
that Singapore Hong Kong Mumbai India
was one of the most incredible
experiences I ever had in my life it was
like I went to a com like a different
planet
just to be over there
a whole different [__] world running
the exact same way as over here they had
their own Airlines they had their own
famous people their own music their own
Superstars and I had no idea who the
[__] anybody was and I'm watching these
these these pop singers getting mobbed
and stuff you know swatching it on TV
um I still don't know that if anybody's
listening over in China I when I landed
in Hong Kong
one of the sickest logos I ever saw
there was a plane and on the tail it had
a dragon
like that was their logo
it's like that's
that's the [__] what do we got over here
we got an orca every once in a while
though they'll paint a plane like
you know but it doesn't seem like a wild
one
seems like one of the ones that has to
do three shows down at Sea World
um
you know they always talk about how
[__] smart those things are you know
those are dumb ones that get caught am I
going Donald Trump here
um
you're a pow I don't respect you uh
drinkable water hey Billy genius tits
uh listening to you talk about finding a
water truck to send to Jackson was
inspiring and stupid at the same time
you're reading off the prices of water
if you wanted
to water a large lawn or fill a pond if
water prices were that cheap I'd park a
truck outside my house please don't kill
the citizens of Mississippi with your
Goodwill uh or you could just say hey
Bill I'm in that industry so I
understand it more
you know
it was it really inspiring
okay because it just seemed like it was
stupid because that's all you that was
inspiring and stupid now here's the next
five sentences are all stupid
you were reading off prices prices of
waters if you wanted to water a large
lawn or fill a pond [__] if water
prices were that cheap I'd park a truck
outside my house
[__] please don't kill the citizens of
Mississippi with your Goodwill [__]
with a little sugar on it
Jesus [__] Christ I mean if if that
isn't the [__] internet right there
I'm trying to find a [__] truck to
fill it up with drinkable water that was
what I was trying to do you [__]
is it what you know kind of you know
this is I think this is why rich people
they don't they know they don't [__]
give a [__] about any of us right they
don't give a [__] look at this this
little [__] move that I was gonna do
on my little mezzanine level of this
[__] Ponzi scheme and I'm getting all
this [__] it's like you know what I'll
[__] I'll send you some more Brown
water right to your house you [__]
go [__] yourself how about a Hollywood
liberal out here
former Prius driver
trying to help you out
how about that
wet your whistle in between whatever
[__] racist thing you're saying
[Music]
all right I know you're just being a
[__] I'm being a [__] back too well we
figured out a [__] way to bring you
something nice all right so there you go
go [__] yourself enjoy yourself
um all right all the way from Africa
uh hey Bill
I don't know how to say this
Mac mcadini Viber I'm sure that means
[__] let me see this I'm gonna look
this up macadini
everybody who understands that word is
laughing right now
am I going to spell this right
Mac uh
macadini
mcadini in English
how can you well that doesn't sound
right that doesn't sound like my
listeners hey Bill how can you Viber
I don't know what I don't get it all
right I'm sure you're insulting me and I
appreciate it and I also appreciate you
listening I have been listening to
podcasts since the pandemic to the
extent that I signed up to Spotify so
that I can listen to your past work
dating back to 2011.
what do you mean [__] kill you guys
you got brown [__] coming out of your
goddamn [__] uh
I [__] hate people
um or do I just hate how stupid I am all
right you're right I was dumb you're
right you're right stupid I thought I
could just fill it up and [__] hose
you guys down
um
you know be hilarious is if a rich black
guy got one got one of those water
trucks and went down there and just
hosed down a bunch of [__] rednecks
sort of doing like the reverse of what
happened to his people
just trying to help out
um all right and I wrote in to say you
really have wait wait wait wait wait I
I've listened to the podcast since the
pandemic to the extent that I signed up
to Spotify
so that I can listen to your past work
dating back to 2011. I didn't know I was
on Spotify what do I get there Spotify
[__] how much money do I get what do I
get huh for every nine million downloads
you give me half a cent
[__] thieven [__]
um and wrote I wrote in just to say you
really have changed for the best yes I
am judging you uh well done this is
probably a white dude from South Africa
2011 Bill and 2022 Bill our day and
night with a hint of eclipse for the
time you freak out
at the kids at the play center yeah
that's true you always give me a male
perspective that my African father can I
was wrong look at that can never give me
oh you guys still going Macho over there
uh by the way you are of the same age as
him and I am 32. I can hear you gasp no
I don't because I would have been a
[__] [__]
I would have been a [__] father and then
my kid would have to listen to a podcast
on the other side of the world to listen
to somebody a little more [__] opened
anyway keep doing the podcast it's a
breath of fresh air in this African heat
regards all the way from air quote
Democratic Zimbabwe yes Bill Africa go
[__] yourself that is amazing
that is amazing
um well thank you so much for listening
oh it says Michelle yes I am a lady you
[__] I thought that was a white dude it
was an African Zimbabwean
woman all right college degree and a
rickshaw that should be a thing guess
the sex and race
um [__] Bears still have the ball
there's just a lot of hair issues on the
[__] Packers
dude Aaron let's picture Aaron Rodgers
to look on his [__] face he's just
like don't do this again
he looked like he was standing outside a
bank that just failed
and all he had was the book
oh look no wait no no no no no no no no
no go go go go go go go go go go go pass
the line of scrimmage run you [__]
whoa this is why I watched the games out
in my garage
um college degree and a rickshaw
okay dear bill I wanted to enter
I want to enter a trade
I always wanted to enter a trade when I
was a kid I was really smart at math I
can still do complex stuff in my head
that's really cool
uh just a little party I have up my
sleeve
um I know someone like that
that is just amazing and loves math and
loves like figuring stuff out like
engineering level stuff it was past the
line of scrimmage loss of down
yeah let's just say loss of Beth loss of
bet and put a picture of me up there
um
just a little party you have up my
sleeve anyway I always wanted to build
stuff and not work in an office I was
convinced to go to college through
though by my parents who are devoid of
any common sense or connection to
reality
Jesus that mathematical brainios can be
a little harsh huh
um
oh I see you wanted to go to trade
school oh they just uh do what they
think you're supposed to do in life
that's another story so here I am five
years after graduating with a double
major and there are no jobs in the city
I live in I've explored other cities and
I'm thinking about moving by the spring
here's the kicker the best job I found
that pays the most and gives me flexible
hours is a rickshaw driver
one of the novelty ways of getting
around a metro
where where do you live
is that the thing with the bike are you
are you writing in from China
I don't know anyway
um should I take this job
I have to look up Rickshaw driver is
that what they call the bicycle things
now
I always thought of being a rickshaw
drive would be a great way to meet
chicks if you were younger Rickshaw
driver
uh images
okay I see the motorized ones in India
which I wrote in one of those [__]
iconic moment in my life
cruising down the [__] streets out
there in Mumbai that was so cool all
right I don't know where you're from all
right but I ended but you know what
doesn't matter where you're from we all
have the same problems
um should I take this job I don't know
anyone who's ever driven him
uh I mean pulled one oh so you're like
literally all right I asked around but
no one
knows anyone who's done it I asked the
guy who would hire me but he barely
speaks my language my concern was
getting injured or run over
would you pull so you like an expat or
something would you pull a rickshaw if
it meant three dollars more an hour or
would you take the safe bet and work at
Walgreens
I mean you're asking a 54 year old man
if I would run down the street with a
couple of fat tourists behind me I mean
um
you know what buddy I'm gonna punt this
one I would I would do
I would do what you want to do I mean
you could you can always get a job at
Walgreens right
you know the amount of people that you
know the amount of drugs that they're
pushing and people that overdose from
shopping there I'm sure that opens up
some Lanes to get rehired
you know that could be like a fun job
you do for the summer over where I lived
it was like kids who got jobs you know
peddling the Swan Boats out in Boston
Common or driving the duck boats and
[__] like that that's probably not this
good thing because that's actually
you're driving something down the street
um
yeah you know if it's three dollars more
an hour and you're in good shape and you
think it's going to be fun
you know I would do that job and
continue to job hunt is what I would do
how about that
but you know just don't [__] up your
back
and all of that stuff I would get a good
masseuse there goes your extra three
dollars an hour all right teachers fly
down oh brother dear bill there's a
teacher that everyone dislikes he's
notorious for being an [__] at every
turn if you if you're Pleasant to him he
comes back even more dickish
yeah well he probably had a bad
childhood
you know couldn't trust people so if
you're being nice to him he doesn't know
how to accept it or thinks that you you
have some sort of angle anyway he said I
was lucky enough to end up in his class
this year he or she says this first week
of school and he's got his fly down
while lecturing a couple people
snickered here and there but mostly my
class is full of nerds because it's an
advanced class no one had the balls to
tell him I decided I was going to be the
guy who told him what's he gonna do fire
me from the classroom plus I had my
rebuttal planned out if he gave me [__]
for telling him so after class I told
him very nicely and discreetly I think
you can do it in front of the class hey
just a heads up you fly us down he
looked at me like he was gonna kill me I
looked back to him confused and
amazingly calm I said should I have not
told you he said you should have you
should leave the class now before I take
action against you for being wise
this is oh he goes this is where I shine
Bill oh you gotta come back we got a
comeback coming can you [__] tackle
somebody listen to my [__] voice is
cracking [__] crack and Tackle
somebody this is where I shine Bill I
said
so you're going to reprimand me for
letting you know that you're exposing
yourself to a classroom full of
teenagers holy [__]
wow and the dagger
from way behind the ark they're heading
to the exits everybody
wow
good for you
holy [__] I couldn't come up with
something like that that's [__] great
he looked at me
with his eyes wide but said nothing so I
kept going and said well I just wanted
to let you know so we didn't have a news
story on our hands you're welcome and I
left
it's the weekend so I won't see him till
that class on Tuesday again did I nail
it Bill did you nail it you [__]
ended it
dude you drove that [__] nail into
the wall like a half an inch you put
spackle over it you covered it up and
then you painted it
see it's [__] over like my goddamn
gambling this week no that was [__]
masterful
and this is what you do on Monday you
walk in if he tries to [__] stare you
down you look right at him look down at
his [__] crotch and then be like nice
work
[Music]
if this flies up
um
[__] that miserable [__]
I I you know
I don't mind somebody being a hard ass
if they're trying to teach your lesson
but if it's just you're [__]
miserable because you're old
you know and you don't like what you're
waking up next to or you don't like how
your life turned out you know at that
point if you are that old person right
now if you [__] hate your life don't
take it out on young people all right
your job now is to try to help them not
make the mistakes you made okay and make
that's how you make the world a better
place so there's not another miserable
old man out there because that's what it
is nice nice sack hold personal file
something don't [__] me don't [__] me
come on
what do we got here no face mask
personal foul tackling the quarterback
don't [__] me
what do we got here what do we got here
it was a sack sorry people
the [__] just happened he didn't would
he pick up the flag he didn't say
anything
um
anyway
oh Jesus Christy [__] triumphed him
boom
look at that like a goddamn dog on a leg
um but he did he he did what he had to
do because he knew that big guy was
gonna [__] destroy
oh no oh no
well
anyway
you know what's
you know what's underrated losing a bet
in the second quarter
it's not so bad it's when they [__]
make you hang around and hang around and
hang around and then go into the prevent
or they fumble I mean somebody on that
[__] play with the Cardinals
somebody's money went one way or the
other on that fumble
just unreal how about Arizona how about
Kyla Murray with that [__] pass man
Jesus Christ
that that did not look good that whole
game I was following the score I was
just like Jesus who did they get rid of
first [__] down damn it
these kids today with the flexing and
screaming and yelling they've been doing
it for 20 years I mean I don't think I
ever saw Jerry Rice do that you just
caught the ball and that was it
foreign
the self-congratulatory you know my new
thing is like I I don't know if I've
talked about this yet I feel like then
like reaction videos
people that film reaction videos that's
the new narcissism
you know what I mean and there's also
this really slimy way of you
putting yourself on the same level of
something
that you have no remote ability to do
you know what I mean
does that make any sense like an amazing
musician
or athlete
song movie or anything like that and for
whatever [__] reason I need to see
your reaction
oh my God
what is the reaction of this [__]
person that that they can't do this [__]
um
I don't I don't you know look
I guess if they just enjoying it
you know what I mean that's not what I
mean I mean like those people
ah [__] it yeah I'm just gonna say rob
you [__] [__] touchdown
didn't even fall down
there you go pose a picture there you go
pose for a picture and I'll do your
little thing
I like when that guy in the Arizona
Cardinals scored the touchdown and then
he took his helmet off and then for
whatever reason the guy who didn't do
anything took his helmet off too and
then ran next to him
he's like oh yeah that's right you're
gonna be on TV I want to be on TV
oh bill now who's the angry old man
because he never made it in the NFL all
right hahaha
somebody sent me an article today
talking about
how they were talking about
um
like sexism in sports or something like
that and they were suggesting that you
know they've been segregated because of
sex
you know which I thought was because of
safety
you know what I mean
um
so now that there's there's talks of of
doing sports in a different way that
it's men and women
like competing with each other which is
uh
you know it that would just be a
different kind of sports
and I was just like listen I am just if
young people want to do it that way I'm
too old to get up out of my chair
and [__] about it
and that that's how I want to be more as
I get older
when I see [__] that doesn't make any
sense I'll still joke about it on stage
but I'll just be like all right
is that how you do in that life you know
does it make you happy okay
I mean I don't get it well bill it's not
for you
it ain't for you
Avatar's back
Jesus Christ I mean how do you how are
you supposed to root for these [__]
giant blue people
I just I don't understand like
I remember I went and I saw that I
bought into the hype and I bought the
[__] 3D glasses
and I'm sitting there and I I don't know
how I must have been an hour and 10
minutes so that's a movie before I
realized that I didn't give a [__] about
anybody in it
like anybody could have got killed in
that movie at any moment I would have
been like all right
okay good one down
[Music]
[Laughter]
um
does anybody else see these Liberty
Mutual commercials and think that's Sam
Rockwell every single time
I always think that's Sam every time I
see it
um all right okay that's it people that
is the podcast everybody thank you so
much for listening thank you everybody
uh is that a Chevy citation in the
background a brown Chevy citation my
buddy I gotta stop doing that I'm not
gonna do these podcasts with the TV on
anymore
uh my buddy had one of those a brown
Chevy a [__] Brown Chevy citation and
the the uh the dirty secret about that
car was when they designed it they
forgot to put the radio in
so
at the last second they put the radio in
and rather than having it horizontal
they put it vertical and they didn't
even change the numbers they just
slammed a radio in there it's like one
of the ugliest cars
I've ever seen it was this really weird
thing where they were trying to have
like big cars and compact cars
like look the same like there's a
Cadillac Seville
from like 1980 or something like that
with a front end looks like the car is
15 feet long and then the back end turns
into like some sort of weird hatchback
the Chevy citation
was like the ugly third cousin
of that CR of that sort of style
um
anyway hey write in I want to hear
married guys what's the thing you know
you're always looking at [__] that you
want to buy but you know you're not
because you got kids
right
what's the thing you look at I always
look at the [__] Porsche Target and I
look at a Harley-Davidson Road King
those are the two things
I find myself looking at the most uh I
want to hear I want to hear what your
what's your American Beauty thing that
you're gonna [__] put in the house or
in the driveway
there's another thing too we just have
too much furniture
I want to get that [__] stand-up
hockey game
you know the one that you played in the
bar
that had like the announcement the puck
shoots up in the air I'm getting one of
those I don't care what piece of
furniture we have to get rid of but I'm
gonna get one of those and I'm gonna
have some epic [__] games against my
kids
um
and I just don't know where I'm gonna
put it I'll just have to I'll get rid of
some [__]
that's what I'll do I'll get rid of [__]
yeah I'll get rid of some [__] all right
I'm just literally talking to myself
here all right go [__] yourselves I'll
check in on you on uh on Thursday the
Patriots get their first victory of the
year one and one baby one and one all
right I'll see you